j'en ai sur autant que toi moi aussi
j'avais un boulot moi aussi j'ai perdu
mais moi aussi j'en ai bavé derrière
je vais toucher 500 euros par mois je
fais comment pour payer toutes les
factures tout ce que je dois celle en
neuf mois c'est celle là est ce que vous
pensez que vous seriez d'accord pour
accepter une fonction en dessous de
celles que vous allez occuper dans votre
ciel entreprises ah oui je prends soin
pour ces messieurs
est-ce que vous avez envisagé la vente
peut-être de l'appartement mais c'est
non c'est non et battant quelle raison
ce serait comme si tout ce que on avait
fait c'était ça s'est vu servir you donc
au niveau des hôtesses je suis solidaire
pour voir ses escales tous les articles
vu qu'il ya pas eu beaucoup de départs
en pré retraite
j'ai essayé de virer du personnel
ouais c'est un joyau qu'est ce qu'il
veut faire moi je pense que pour ma
santé mentale
je préfère tirer un trait passer à autre
chose
est ce que ça fait de moi un lâche bon
qu'il fasse sa première fois mais avant
ça mais vous avez été filmée
j'en ai dit confirmer
thierry vous confirmez
tous